to be ethical if you're a billionaire
today the thing that you need to do is
give up control and power and yourself I
want the money as much as we want your
power so someone should make a company
produce something employ people add
value and then you oh so you'll steal it
let's get two actually I think this is
more important because kind of like with
the 2016 campaign
everyone was focusing on Hillary Clinton
and we focused on Bernie you can go back
and watch those videos we have the most
viewed videos on Bernie Sanders in that
2016 period and we thought okay Hillary
Clinton is it's going to be effectively
a coronation right with Hillary Clinton
but Bernie is the movement candidate
that's the one that you have to dissect
and ridicule so that people see the
absurdity for what it is
same thing here if people are just
focusing on Klobuchar or Warren and I
understand their way further left I
think it's important to still recognize
that Bernie and now aoc these are the
movement candidates that you need to be
more concerned with so that thing said
at an event that was commemorating
Martin Luther King jr. yes one of them
nailed a thing to the door of the church
different more than the black guy that
won Alexandria Castillo Cortes gave an
interview with author tintin the heat
Tunis he seat and he coached and he
sikhye well here you eat oats yeah
another thing that I've been really
thinking and sitting with today is that
we there's this gun rights protest
that's happening down in Richmond and on
MLK Day but here's the image that has
struck him okay we're out of time is
that when we go out and march for the
dignity and the recognition of the lives
of people like Freddie gray and Eric
garner the whole know managing of brown
no matter portraying a cure without a
gun in sight and here are all of these
people flying Confederate flags with
semi-automatic weapons and there's
almost no police officers at that
protest
okay by the way she says a couple of
things we'll get to the facts with it
actually
remember the guy says on MLK Day well as
though guns are Luther King jr. by the
applied for concealed carry permit to
defend himself and was denied despite
qualifying right MLK was not anti Second
Amendment at all and that should point
us to the dangers of giving over that
authority and autonomy to the government
because at that point the government
didn't provide equal rights to blacks
and they had their justifications well
guess what that can change at any that
can change any point if the government
is in charge of granting and recognizing
rights as opposed to it being granted by
in great and by the way something else
it's also based on a false premise she
said oh and there is not there all these
guns and not Donna not a police officer
and said there were three different
police forces working overtime and like
like like a Johnson the event was
peaceful unlike the black lives matter
protest by the way he she didn't
mentioned Ferguson hands up don't shoot
started with Mike Brown yeah
little word of advice don't try to punch
a cop or pistol whip him with his own
gun just first starters so in Ferguson
theater the cost the city millions of
dollars Dallas twelve officers were shot
five were killed
so again which side would really need
more police at their events not to
mention the little fact that an aunt if
a member tried to firebomb an ice
facility after being inspired by a
o'seas concentration camp rhetoric and I
want to be really clear here it was it
wasn't like some guy in Christchurch
then mentioning Oh Candace Owens as a
troll job this person believed that
there were concentration camps going on
it's really more like a pizza gate
comparison we don't have a Left Party in
the United States the democratic party's
not he's just doing this that's all him
which is remarkable because it's flat
is a cemetery Trula quests or center
conservative parties hold on a second
there is no Left Party the Democratic
establishment that they're they're
moderate deep do you mean like do you
mean on immigration where you guys are
for reasonable immigration reform border
security oh no wait a second you are for
not only completely open borders and no
wall but against not deporting we're not
talking about dreamers or children you
are against deporting serial violent
felons provided that they currently live
in sanctuary cities
and you're against sending back
criminals who are in our prisons
illegally oh okay well you must mean the
Democrats are among what they're more
moderate on abortion say for things like
limitations that most Americans even who
identify as pro-choice like twenty week
limits I don't know maybe the first trip
wait no you mean the entire democratic
party with the exception of Tulsi
Gabbard support abortion up until the
baby crowns oh my gosh so I don't know
maybe the Democrats when you think
they're centrist on firearms right where
maybe they're just talking about making
sure that violent felons don't get
firearms and wait no hon that's already
the case oh you're talking about the
dissenting opinions in Heller versus DC
in the entire Democratic Party who want
to make all semi-automatic firearms
illegal
what do you call us like what do you
mean Democrats are moderate on taxes and
they live in a progressive tax code
where I don't know maybe like 37 percent
of the top racket or maybe our corporate
tax should be comparable to other
nations like Sweden oh no wait you're
okay with a 90 percent tax and you want
us to have the highest corporate tax in
the industrialized world I just I think
there's a disconnect
you crazy horrible human being very
sound senator conservative yeah we go
there what through abortion guns taxes
immigration right now say what okay
story that's not told is the impact on
our collective psyche hmm on the island
what is this sounds like the turtle
humping a work boot
treats them as treats us as full
citizens because we know it doesn't you
know my own family it's like they had
all of these emergency backpacks ready
to go and rations because they knew that
no one was gonna come and she's not mr.
Starkey and to know that a society does
not care for you has a profound impact
on one psyche remember how we talked
about ascribing intent yeah so not only
did she just describe motive and intent
knowing they don't care about you but
then also attributed non-existent policy
to it or actually this goes back lest
you you have forgotten all the way back
to 2017 with San Juan mayor
it was claiming that Trump was
withholding relief aid I don't have you
guys remember that but if you recall
actually it was the mayor who hadn't
attended any meetings in Puerto Rican
officials had they completely failed to
coordinate delivery of the supplies so
even those that they had received
remained completely unopened look in
that picture right there
that's a press conference in front of an
open supply box that's like Donkey Kong
country's banana horn what where where
whenever could these supplies be because
Americans have Porto Ricans of course
and the supplies actually set so long
that some of them you couldn't be used
anymore yeah because they didn't
distribute there right well now okay so
with the recent earthquake this is
obviously Bert Alma thoughts and prayers
that the people of Puerto Rico of course
Puerto Rican government has repeated the
same cycle with loads of supplies
remaining and warehouses not being
distributed to those in need I guess
then America it's American fault
51st state fingers crossed
the problem with Puerto Rico is not the
United States it's not our conservatism
it's not free enterprise it is the
bloated bureaucratic government that you
al see view as the solution to all
problems when you talk about taking out
big businesses when you talk about fair
distribution when you talk about more
centralized regulation who are you
talking about the exact kind of people
government official
mayors governors so I don't know the
entire maybe it's a part Porto Rico I
don't know exactly
I know important people the point is you
want them to be in charge of these
disasters exclusively you want them to
be in charge of medical aid that's also
why you want to take away tax exempt
status from churches who by the way
provide an overwhelming amount of relief
to a lot of these foreign countries we
did it here with a hurricane RV yeah at
one point they don't want to say because
by the way unless you forget the
argument is we just did that so it's a
tax deduction right right right
we raised several hundred thousand
dollars for Hurricane Harvey because we
would pay a few thousand dollars left in
taxes you [ __ ] notification bell and
hit all notifications on the bell if
you've hit the notification bell before
and you're subscribed because now
apparently the notification bell does
not alert you of all uploads or the
livestreams new video goes up every
single night with the exception of
Sunday and of course join Mudd Club
LOTOS petter comm slash mug Club because
that is what allows us to continue to
produce this content for you and like 80
percent more content there in the juror
blaze TV catalog all right I think we
have more of this this broad next clip
sat on a couch maybe a lot see thousands
maybe nice sectional a fainting couch a
modern-day slave wages and in some cases
real a real modern-day slavery
depending on where you are now in in
terms of food production not in this
country made that money off the backs of
undocumented people
you made that money off of the backs of
black and brown people being paid off a
living wage under a living wage earning
that money off of the backs of single
mothers single mothers and all of these
people who are literally dying because
they can't afford to live and so no one
I like her hype man couch is what the
joke's on you I was in a day bed it's
Americans exploiting black and brown
people paying them slave wages
let me ask how about the brown people
paying brown people going rate
sweetheart let's get the bear trade bull
I'm sure this thing buying me so much
you see ten people talk about like like
coffee or whatever it is if they're
buying at the store cacao which is a
stupid term it's cocoa it's cocoa it's
cocoa
you just haven't roasted it stop saying
cacao it doesn't change what it is hope
you do so you see this fair trade label
on there and what happens they tell you
the story right they go well it's fair
trade because if you don't pay fair
trade these people in these countries we
don't realize they're being exploited
and they're only making $1 a day and you
don't ask them well what are they making
with your fair trade cocoa about a buck
fifty further there they don't provide
the context for example I think we have
a source your ivory coast agricultural
workers make on average four dollars a
day those who work for Fairtrade
certified companies see it boosted to a
whopping six ooh
so they're not so much paid an American
minimum wage you need to provide the
scale and the context and on top of that
this goes back to ALCS false claimed
with the living wage claims which
doesn't really mean anything because it
changes every single year yes they were
debunked by Washington Post last year
let's do you think that it's fake news
the company of course that Alexandria a
Cascio Nina Pinta Santa Maria Cortez
one that she always takes a Mattia is
amazon for not paying its employees evil
living wage he's evil billionaires right
they didn't make these companies they
just sat on their what was it love seat
they just they just really pretty much
they sat in there beanbag didn't make
these companies where there are now
hundreds of thousands of people who have
jobs right Amazon alone employed 750,000
people in 2019 it sounds like a lot but
you want to know what AOC would do what
she's talking about this if someone like
her so it's not necessarily about AOC
because she probably won't make it to
some kind of serious a national platform
as far as presidents or something like
that she's crazy you can see the are you
calling okay don't read the horse they
were you dropped yeah do you want to
know what someone like AOC would do if
they were in power nationally as they
much about Donald Trump and one of the
most Bergen economies that we've ever
seen
look at her district in New York where
she gave Amazon the boot despite the
overwhelming support of her constituents
wanting to bring Amazon in along with
its twenty five thousand jobs below a
living wage mind you 150,000 dollars
average annual salary yeah that's more
than so she's for the workers yeah we
should just toss that to AOC think about
that for a second twenty five thousand
jobs yeah in Queens gone one hundred
fifty thousand dollars a year right the
point is if you just if you think that
that's exploitation
you just hate companies that aren't
government-owned you want to nationalize
everything don't tell me that it's about
sixteen dollars an hour don't even tell
me it's about twenty five dollars an
hour right you kicked out twenty five
thousand jobs
averaging one hundred and fifty thousand
dollars a year it's it that's over
you're done nobody likes lying losers
with crazy eyes next clip I think it's
totally fine and human and natural to
feel that way
so my joints are okay I think your
Jordans are okay good to see in
primaries are straight
like living it while fighting for a
better world the same nike famous for
exploiting sweatshop labor conditions in
other countries that we don't allow with
our capitalist system by the way here in
the united states but it's ok when it's
night because they support sodomy and
this ass so that's fine i think we have
just the last clip of a OCS sir thank
you yes thank you
to be ethical if you're a billionaire
today the thing that you need to do is
give up control and power and you're
second I don't want money as much as we
want your power we don't want as you
learned it right it's a a billionaire to
fund this or that but we want to demand
is to change these systems change the
business model that has exploited so
many people huh I wasn't looking at my
iPad I just honest I was looking down
because I'm very sad it's embarrassing
for her we want your power I don't
really get me should make a company
produce something employ people add
value and then you oh so you'll steal it
right Stephen you're misunderstanding
billionaires as she stated before and
never make a billion dollars they they
hate you they take that's not taking no
it's not tonight a Google is into the
mix we're murky on the rule book yet
idea of why that is horrible Jeff Bezos
I don't agree with his politics we've
talked about that quite a bit but he's
not some guy who was raised wealthy with
a silver shoulders mother this is a guy
this is the American Dream created less
I keep saying lest I should stop it's
good Lester Holt that's not on your
money we have to bring that back up he
does he look stylish muppet us in case
you've forgotten ever saw was a
bookseller for a long time it didn't
become what it is today accidentally I
don't agree with his politics but what
gives me the right to take anything from
just bait Jeff Bezos this is this is
the concentrate they want to take from
people aoc who've actually worked to
create something it would be to give you
a more kind of direct comparison I think
I was talking with our researcher reg
who's brilliant just he's so strong he
squats like 630 pounds like a
competitive power at 180 pound
bodyweight gee I said imagine this if we
could put on just sort of this these
helmets like I think you've seen them in
Star Trek where you switch bodies and
you've done all of this work and for
eight years you work to create this
total so you can compete in a national
level in powerlifting and all of a
sudden I just go and I suck up your
power because here's the thing she's
talking about giving us your power well
we see with Puerto Rico or the
government even the United States they
don't give up the power once they've
taken it the blowers going somewhere you
are talking aoc about displacing power
from people who are beholden to adding
value lest they lose power I said it
again versus you who will have the power
subsequently regardless of having earned
it and we should know this anyone who
has a serious fire I'm a high caliber
firearm and has never used it never
trained with it that's a bad idea put
someone under a 500 pound barbell who's
never worked their way up to create that
strength it doesn't end well these
people who want all of the powers she
just said haven't earned it it will
collapse and they will fold under the
weight and subsequently the American
people and I understand why if someone
had to work to create this let's even go
back to Jeff bezels I don't know there's
politics why is it immoral for mr. Bezos
to want to keep what he's created but
it's not immoral for you or me to want
to take it again displacing this power
from billionaires you're going to
displace it to people who made porto
rico happen hey if you enjoyed this
video subscribe or hit the notification
bell and hit all notifications because
not all notifications work now if you
just hit the normal notification bell i
think there's some videos playing in
boxes but of course do you consider
subscribing at a lot of credit calm
slash mug club because it's a bunch of
content that could never make it onto
youtube and I think the the box is
playing there's a video playing in a box
with